[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
dans le cadre de l'opération d'intérêt
national paris saclay l'état souhaité
faire de ce territoire un démonstrateur
de la ville durable et à ce titre le
père paris-saclay mène plusieurs actions
emblématiques dont le réseau des changes
de chaleur de froid qui est une
composante majeure de la stratégie
énergétique des foyers ici sur le campus
urbain puisque ce réseau d'échangés sur
le réseau va être le maillon central de
toute la chaîne énergétique avec du
couplage sur les réseaux électriques
l'intégration de panneaux
photovoltaïques à terme et aussi la
valorisation de ressources agricoles
ce réseau des chances de chaleur et de
froid s'articule autour d'une boucle
tempéré une douche le tempérer qui va à
partir de
d'une installation centralisée va capter
la chaleur issue de la géothermie donc
qui vient de la nappe de l'albien à 700
mètres de profondeur et ensuite la
boucle d'eau tempérée d'emmener les
calories sur différentes sous-station de
10 lots qui sont situées en sous-sol de
grands bâtiments du campus urbain et
dans ces sous stations d'îlots des
thermes au frigo pont vont à partir des
30 degrés de la boucle tempéré vont
faire du show à 60 degrés et du foie à 7
degrés et ce show et se fera sont
ensuite distribués aux bâtiments de
chaque îlot dans chaque quartier
rien n'est perdu les bâtiments en fait
échanges leur énergie c'est un bâtiment
qui va avoir des besoins de froid va
être en fait indirectement un producteur
de chaux pour un bâtiment voisin qui lui
va avoir des besoins de chauffage eau
chaude sanitaire et en même temps le
réseau permettent de récupérer aussi
toutes les énergies du territoire donc
la géothermie on l'a dit aimé aussi d
énergie de récupération de la chaleur
fatale par exemple de supercalculateurs
ou d'autres grandes infrastructures
scientifiques qui sont présentes ici sur
le territoire aujourd'hui on a déjà une
douzaine de bâtiments raccordés sur le
réseau des grandes écoles centrale
supélec l'institut mines télécom des
résidences étudiantes qui accompagnent
ces écoles on a aussi déjà deux hôtels
des commerces
très bientôt on va avoir des logements
familiaux à la rentrée qui vont qui vont
être alimentés et à terme ce sera une
centaine de bâtiments
sur le campus qui seront alimentées en
show est en froid avec une énergie à
plus de 60 % d'origine renouvelable ou
de récupération
[Musique]